so this photograph of kim kardashian and
p davidson going on a roller coaster
holding hands is going viral
over this past weekend travis barker
kourtney kardashian kim and pete
davidson went on on like a
theme park day with a bunch of their
friends and kim and pete were seen
hanging out so now a lot of people are
speculating that they may be dating yeah
but but if you're on a ride and you grab
your friend like does it make me gay
since i grabbed my friend on splash
mountain a little bit really so if i
oh it's been a minute that drop is
pretty heavy if i go
yeah
that's gay yeah that's okay but but uh i
that that if i if i'm dating kim and i
see that
we're gonna have some talk we're gonna
have what are you doing what the [ __ ]
are you doing
what is this she was like babe we're
both scared nah you're interlocking your
hands i'd be more casual i'd be more
like i'd be more pissed off as the asian
girl in the front with a shitty
she's gonna go viral
your friend's like do you see you kim
kardashian post you everywhere she's oh
[ __ ]
terrible
i was wearing diapers
thank god uh i'm gonna [ __ ]
i think people are mainly assuming this
just because p davidson is known for
bagging bad [ __ ] he
you know god bless maybe he's really
funny he's probably got some swagger to
him you know yeah he's awesome of course
he's known for having a giant dick
and then he i love what he said and
especially he goes ariana grande they
planned that so that for the rest of my
life girls would be disappointed this is
a very intelligent
nice fight this is a very intelligent
person oh he's great i love pete now for
the rest of my life
they're like really but she said yeah
that was great that's funny
yeah the big dick energy came from him
yeah